バンカ
ラジオ俺の名前は天才小学生今日は町に
待った遠足の日
だおいの人
てあんたの方がうるさいわよ静かにして
ちょうだいすいませ
んお開いた
おいなんで先生が座るんだよ何が悪いんだ
前に立ってた人が座るっていうルールだろ
そんなルールに縛てばっかじゃないのか
こんなもん早いもん
がた
残念遅かった
[音楽]
ね先生優先席を必要としてる人がいるのに
まだ席を譲らないつもりです
か乗客の皆さん見てくださいこの男優先席
を引こうとしている方がいるのにまだ席を
戦理をしています皆さん一緒に
譲れ
譲れ譲れ譲れ譲れ譲れ
譲れ譲れあし譲れ
[拍手]
もいお前らは一生しれたロを走てろ俺に社
のレールは必要ない皆さん聞きましたか彼
にレールは必要ないらしいですそれじゃ皆
さん移動しましょうこちこち
ああ邪魔者たちが消えて先生したささきも
使い放題だぜ
ヤッホーお望み通り先生はレールのない道
を走って
[音楽]
くださいイエ
[拍手]
[音楽]
お腹が痛くてトイレにこもってたら遅刻し
ちゃいましたおみんな揃ったなじゃあド
するぞよ最初君じゃけぽいそれじゃあスは
警察他は泥棒だ逃げろ
[音楽]
なんだこれ面白そうな映画だな
よしおえキーたのうんちのせいで壊れ
ちまったよ
[音楽]
んこっちだ
な
おいしょ待ってろよそこにいるのはバレて
んだぞ
らどこだどこ
[音楽]
だ見つけ
た次のターゲットはやお前速のなきゃ足
遅い
たろなめやがって
[拍手]
待てじ
あねきたく今助けるからねこ
[音楽]
こじり
うわー何
おタッチ
さてと残りは先生
だあれ見つからない
な劇場内での映画の撮影録音は犯罪です
楽しみだ
な裕子
さん僕と結婚して
ください喜んでふじゃねえかんだこそれが
延長
[音楽]
さお客さん何やってるんですか
ひそういえば先生どこ行ったんだろう
[音楽]
甘い先生助けて逆に助けてくれ待ちなさい
えそれじゃあお弁当の時間だ弁当弁当弁当
ちなみに今回の遠足お菓子持ち込み禁止
だって覚えてるよなやすももちろんです
抜き打ちお弁当チェックまずは
[音楽]
こじりマメロだよ見た目だけ気にする
タイプの弁当だな次切い
た何の特徴もないつまらん弁当だな次
やすお前のお母さんの料理の下手さには
同情するよ次ユト弁当は貧乏なので作って
もらえませんでしたそそっかそれは残念
だった
なよしお前ら約束守れるじゃんかそれ
じゃあいただき
んところでこのマメロ何でできてるのかな
あだよそっ
かあれお米は太陽の光で解けないはずだぞ
おかしいなもしかしておかしかなジだよ
バッシー
だ今回お弁当がチェックされるのは想定
済みだから俺は水藤に大好きなコーラを
忍ばせておいたんだ
やす今のは何の音だあれトーマスとか
シポこらじゃ
か先生実は聞いたもお菓を隠し持って
ますは連の下
ですごめんとすぐコメントすればこの
メントスは
見逃すごごめんなさい嘘だよシ
だす自分がバレたからって僕を売ったな
ごめん聞いたでもこうするしかなかったん
だよどういうことだよ
[音楽]
甘いメントスコーラだ
[拍手]
[音楽]
今日最後の企画はハイキングだ先生お腹
痛いからトイ行ってき
[音楽]
ます先生本当にこの道でってるのてるはず
だ
が
[音楽]
うわどこだ
ここ出口が塞がれてるよ携帯の充電を切れ
て連絡しもないこりゃまずいぞ
[拍手]
みんな落ち着け何か解決策があるはず
だ先日晩から小学校の生徒と先生が行方
不明になりました僕がトイレに入ってる間
にみんないなくなっちゃったんですえ
みんな
どこお腹空いたよおい帰りたいよ食料も水
もないもう時間の問題か
あそういえ
ば生徒の弁当でお腹いっぱいになって自分
の分を食べてなかっ
た
[音楽]
いただき先生何食べようとしてんですか
自分の弁当を食べて何が悪い食の裏には
一緒の
[音楽]
き金だ
金なるほどここは炭鉱なのかカカカカカ
カカカカカカカカカカカカカカカカ先生
そのまま掘り進めるダないカカカカカカカ
カ
うわガスだ逃げろ
こっち
だファイヤ
うた助かっ
た
はいみんな心配したよおお前いたんだな
おどこへ行って
たみんなこの前の遠足では非常に怖い思い
をさせたそこで先生はこのクラスの担任を
やめることになったそりゃそうだろうな
そして先生は新たに復興長になることが
決定した
はあ生徒を守る勇敢な行動をした先生に
小さの声が上がっていますいやリスクの
ある決断でしたが爆発を利用するしか
助かる日がなかったん
ですちなみに金で動けてはははあんたの
せいでこうなったんだろうがお
ちゃちゃちゃちゃチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録よろしく
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録チャンネル
登録よろしく最初はチャンネル登録
チャンネル登録チャンネル登録